♪♪♪
>>> SIT DOWN.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, MR. BUNTING
WILL NO LONGER BE TEACHING HERE
AT WINDERMERE.
AS YOUR PRINCIPAL, I WILL BE
TAKING OVER THIS CLASS UNTIL THE
END OF THE YEAR.
MR. DALTON, WILL YOU PLEASE TELL
ME WHERE YOU LEFT OFF IN THE
TEXTBOOK?
MR. ROONEY?
SINCE MR. DALTON CANNOT BE
BOTHERED WHERE DID YOU LEAVE
OFF?
>> WE KIND OF SKIPPED AROUND A
BIT.
>> FINE.
THEN WE WILL START FROM THE
BEGINNING.
MR. --
[ KNOCK AT THE DOOR ]
>> EXCUSE ME.
I CAME TO COLLECT MY PERSONALS.
SHOULD I COME BACK AFTER CLASS?
>> GET THEM NOW, MR. BUNTING.
>> MR. KELLOGG, CONTINUE.
PLEASE READ FROM PAGE ONE.
>> WE HAVE RIPPED OUT ALL THE
PAGES, SIR.
>> TURNED THEM INTO HATS.
>> THEN YOU CAN BORROW MINE.
NOW, READ.
>> POETRY SHOULD NOT BE FUN.
IT SHOULD BE OPPRESSIVE AND THE
READER SHOULD HATE IT.
POEMS ARE FROM 100 YEARS AGO.
THEY WERE WRITTEN BY A BUNCH OF
DEAD MEN TO PUNISH CHILDREN, THE
ARTS IN GENERAL ARE FOR WOMEN
AND HOMOSEXUALS.
WHEN YOU READ A POEM, YOU SHOULD
NEVER FEEL EMOTION.
IN SUMMARY, POEMS STINK.
>> MR. BUNTING, WE DIDN'T WANT
YOU TO GET FIRED, THEY MADE US
SIGN THAT PAPER.
>> SIT DOWN, MR. DALTON!
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> LEAVE, MR. BUNTING, RIGHT
NOW.
♪♪♪
>> I SING MY SONG FOR ALL TO
HEAR.
>> SIT DOWN THIS INSTANT.
>> I SING MY SONG FOR ALL TO
HEAR.
>> I WILL HAVE YOU BOTH EXPELLED
IF YOU DO NOT SIT DOWN
IMMEDIATELY.
MR. BUNTING, LEAVE.
>> I SING MY SONG FOR ALL TO
HEAR.
>> I SING MY SONG --
[ SCREAMS AND LAUGHTER ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO TAKE OFF.
YOU GUYS HAVE MY E-MAIL AND
EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
GO WINDERMERE.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]